[Applaudissements]
évidente a déjà installé wyeth dans la
clinique la bastille certains plus cyril
j'entends laurent qui on répète ce que
je dis allez quel est le secret de votre
longévité
le botox quelle est la pire chose que
vous ayez vu dans les loges de c'est mon
choix faits dans la salle aux parts de
bâtiments reflet dans la glace
non mais c'est vrai je ne m'aime de
toute manière je ne m'aime pas donc moi
j'ai eu plein de miroir chez moi je
passe devant je me perds jamais
voyez vous la belle selon vous pourquoi
n'avez-vous toujours pas trouvé le grand
amour
je l'avais trouvé hier et je l'avais
trouvé ya eu des morts ce vote
il est mort ce matin au pire sujets que
vous ayez traité j'ai couché avec un
chien aveugle annonce assez dégueu
non ça je peux pas salir et j ai qu'un
chien aveugle c'est le rock avant que
ces trophées mais parce que l ol est
créé d'appliquer au c3 où la pire
animatrice encore en activité non non je
réponds jamais à ces questions basiques
on vous répondra non hassiba fille va
répondre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hollande van der bien sûr ferry merci
rythme en vertu de la partie
[Applaudissements]